la parole est à notre collègue michel
bouvard pour le groupe les républicains
doivent et la part eau merci monsieur le
président de la question s'adresse à
madame la secrétaire d'état chargée du
numérique madame madame la ministre
l'économie numérique se développe c'est
une chance pour la création de valeur
c'est une chance pour les services à nos
concitoyens
c'est aussi un défi pour les recettes de
l'état
parce que cette économie numérique
échappe en grande partie à la
contribution aux charges générales de la
société au travers du paiement de
l'impôt
les géants de l'internet optimise et
puis le commerce électronique qui se
développe 57 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires dans notre pays plus
11% échappe en grande partie à la tva
qui est l'une des principales recettes
fiscales de notre pays aujourd'hui nous
avons des sites qui pourraient se faire
enregistrer des plateformes
elles ne font pas où elles le font très
peu nous avons un commerce ceux qui
transfèrent qui passe par dessus les
frontières et qui échappe
là aussi au paiement de la tva puisque
les colis sont tous déclarés à moins de
22 euros et bénéficie donc de la
franchise depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois la commission des finances de notre
assemblée autour du rapporteur général
du budget de manière consensuelle
majorité opposition à travailler formulé
un certain nombre de propositions pour
faire évoluer notre système fiscal est
plutôt que de toucher des objets
matériels de percevoir la fiscalité au
moment de la transaction financière nous
avons également fait un certain nombre
de propositions concernant l'économie
collaborative qui elle aussi se
développe et qui vit dans un flou
s'agissant de ce que le citoyen doit
déclarer ou pas déclarée au niveau de
l'impôt sur le revenu nous avons fait
des propositions qui permettent qu il y
à une franchise d'impôt qui ne pénalise
pas le développement des sociétés de ce
secteur et qui permettent aussi d'avoir
les recettes fiscales attendues
même la ministre qu'elle suit le
gouvernement tente il donner aux
propositions faites par votre commission
des finances la parole
madame axel le maire secrétaire d'état
chargé du numérique madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur michel bouvard les rapports sur
le e-commerce et l'économie collaboratif
que vous avez réalisé avec certains de
vos collègues de la commission des
finances pose les bonnes questions je
vous remercie pour la qualité de ses
travaux qui permettront d'alimenter la
réflexion comme l'action gouvernementale
car derrière des questions d'apparence
très technique
la question qui se pose plus
fondamentalement seidel celle de la
capacité de l'état à collecter l'impôt
qui lui est dû alors vous proposer le
prélèvement la source de la tva
cela pourrait constituer un dispositif
innovant et il faut effectivement
travaillé à cette piste mais d'ores et
déjà certaines difficultés apparaissent
par exemple cela supposerait de prévoir
une démarche obligatoire pour identifier
ceux particuliers comme entreprises qui
seraient déjà en franchise de tva et qui
devrait donc échapper au prélèvement
automatique de 20% que vous proposez
cela supposerait de tenir compte de
l'impact négatif sur la trésorerie des
entreprises du e-commerce et surtout
pour les pme qui en ce moment
connaissent un essor considérable de
leur activité économique grâce au
commerce électronique et qui ne
pourraient plus collecté la tva sur
leurs ventes mais continuerait pour
autant de la payés sur leurs achats
cela supposerait de mobiliser les
banques dans toute la chaîne d'achat
parce qu'elle devrait connaître le taux
applicable la qualité d'assujetti ou non
des différents acteurs est en contact
direct avec la banque du vendeur banques
situées très certainement dans un autre
pays et puis enfin cela supposerait de
supporter le coût informatique d'un
dispositif très complexe
en plus de devoir modifier des textes
européens en vigueur dont la directive
de 2006 sur le système commandes de la
tva
bref tout cela est compliqué mais le
gouvernement est absolument conscient du
problème particulièrement lié au
paiement de la tva et prend des mesures
dans la bonne direction je donnerai
exemple l'article 3 du plf de mauco pure
qui a été adopté propose d'abaisser le
seuil de chiffre d'affaires à partir
duquel la tva est due en france 200
milles à 35000 euros
c'est un pas dans la bonne travailleront
ensemble du numérique la contraction
merci madame la ministre